Here we go in five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
And all the fucking people that make me feel lazy in this world is to,
okay.
It made me feel you and the rock you fuckers don't look like.
Do you ever sleep?
And not enough.
No.
Days off.
That's what I love is unattractive ass.
He's a,
he's a,
he's a person that,
that motivates me and inspires me in the fact that we're,
we're coworkers.
We're friends.
Um,
I think is a,
I think it's like a,
it's a blessing.
It's a blessing to be around that.
Yeah.
Because it truly,
it's,
it's uplifting.
You know,
it makes you,
it just makes you weed out to circle.
When you're around people that truly give you,
like,
uh,
give you some good [inaudible] a good value to you in your life,
you then look at those that don't,
and you can,
you can then push away.
So I'm big on,
I'm big on personality.
I'm big on energy.
I'm big on will.
And once,
uh,
I believe that is contagious.
So if you have a,
a bunch of laziness and a bunch of bullshit around you,
naturally is going to feed off.
You're gonna find yourself becoming what's in your environment.
So I feel the exact same way.
And when I see it go,
can I see that in you?
I see that in you.
I feel like it's a scene that avatar.
I see you.
Yeah.
But a guy like that,
I always wonder like,
how much of that is,
look,
I've had sleep experts on the podcast and tell you like,
like this real problems.
If you don't get enough sleep like you could,
you have a much higher risk of Alzheimer's on this other serious issues.
But I see a guy like the rock,
I'm like,
how the fuck does he sleep?
Well,
where's the room for sleep?
You know that,
that's true.
I can't say that,
um,
that I've witnessed the sleep patterns,
but he's,
he's a late ass,
so he does,
I know he's sleeping at some point because like,
you should play on where are we writing on these?
God Damn it,
he's getting his rest,
which is well deserved.
Um,
but you know,
when you,
when you say you had these sleep experts and stuff on,
it's always a thing that I go back and forth about because what is enough sleep
like I'm a person.
I function high off of six to seven hours.
Yeah.
Six seven hours.
I'm,
I'm functioning.
Yeah,
five hours.
I'm great.
Do I do the five hour thing all the time?
No,
but if I have to,
I'm fine.
Um,
I don't need the eight and a nine.
I thought that's too much for me.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I'm an early riser and now,
and I'm getting older,
you know,
if I can get in that bed by nine 30 or 10 on a day off work day,
I'm very happy with that.
But then I'm up at five 30 I'm up at five.
So what is enough sleep?
What did they tell you is enough?
So really depends on the person.
There are people that have a gene where they can just sleep four hours at night.
That's fine.
You might call it.
I got that.
Is that a,
does it,
what does that,
does that mean motherhood is gold?
What does that,
what does it means?
You've got gene [inaudible].
I got some shit,
but there are,
there are people that just don't need as much.
They can,
they can go a long time without sleep diagnosed me,
I'm one of those people he brought you might be,
I bet a lot of high functioning people are,
cause your body tends to get more efficient.
You know,
like you're,
you're always going,
you're always burning and hard so your body's like,
when it's time to shut down,
it's like shut down.
Get that five,
six hours in.
All right.
I will,
I will confess this.
I am an amazing Catnapper.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm one of those guys,
if you stop talking to me long enough,
I'm a fault slip right here.
I something about silence and just not doing anything and I just,
well it's probably,
you're probably going on momentum all the time.
You probably,
you're probably going on motivation and momentum.
Okay.
Then when your body has his break,
you probably was like,
we could use a little sleep right here.
It's 100% right.
I'm dead serious.
That's,
I know for sure that that's accurate cause I'm catnapping heartbeat.
Do you feel like you've hit a good balance?
So this is why I was wondering about with guys like you or guys like the rock.
When I look at your Instagram,
your social media,
and you're just constantly going like,
God damn.